pat is in Springfield Illinois welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Pat hello thank
you for taking my call
sure I'm a little nervous okay we've
never lost a patient how can I help I'm
a grandma I have got four grandchildren
and the first one is going into high
school in the fall so she's our test
case and so we've been talking about
college since it's coming up soon and
we're trying to avoid student loans
because it seems like that's a big
problem and everybody's debt that I've
heard of
we've got 529 accounts for all four of
the kids we've had them since they were
all born but they're not going to
probably cover the entire four years I
hope they get it gets through two years
the rest I think she's going to have to
buckle down and try to get scholarships
grant run job
what I was wondering is should she just
go ahead for the rest of her college
life get loans as she needs them and
then when she graduates
we see what the bottom line is just pay
them all off before there's any interest
no no I would never go to college on
student loan debt ever not get any never
okay there's three things that she can
do and that you guys can do together in
addition to paying in addition to piling
up cash between now and the time she's
there and if you get her through two
years that's really about four years
from now that you've got to build up
four years three and four right but the
biggest the biggest problem the biggest
cause of student loan debt is college
choice choosing a school you can afford
do not buy a Bentley when you have a
Chevrolet pocketbook right champagne
taste beer pocketbook you've heard the
saying right right and I have never
hired someone or not hired someone and I
have 800 almost 900 team members based
on where they went to school
uh-huh a few colleges that are real
close to where they live
here we go so we live at home they will
be the first one there's two things that
people buy when they go to college on
student loans and they spend about equal
parts on each one is tuition and books
the other is the college life in quotes
the apartment with a jacuzzi and a
skylight in a racquetball court the oh I
have to join this or I have to join that
oh you know I have to have a certain
amount of money to do this or that and
eat out all the time and oh and the
money people spend on food and board and
lifestyle almost equals what they spend
on the school right and when they're
being stupid
okay now because the part because we
forget the purpose of going to college
is not to graduate with a degree in beer
pong it's to graduate with knowledge and
an actual degree and that's the purpose
now if you can gather up some money and
have some of those other experiences
that's fine I'm not mad about that but
the idea that you you you rationalize
and say I had to borrow money because I
couldn't afford to go to school is
absolute hogwash because you can go to
school a state school the average
tuition in America is $12,000 a year
that's thousand dollars a month you can
make 1,500 a month delivering pizzas and
walking dogs and babysitting uh-huh and
so there's a one number one is go to a
college you can afford and stay home for
two years into a community college is
even better okay right number two is
work I'm not talking to you I'm talking
to her uh-huh work while you're in
school and don't work at minimum wage
floppin whoppers right those numbers
don't work you can make $20 an hour
cleaning people's toilets all being a
maid uh-huh and that's you know you can
make that kind of money walking dog
so do whatever start your own little
business cut grass I don't care work at
something you make good money at and
work your butt off while you're in
college and oh by the way then you won't
have the money to party or the time to
party some partying is going down grades
are going up it's amazing people who
work in school have a higher GPA than
those that don't
isn't that interesting yeah that's
something she's gonna have to do yeah
number three take the AC T repeatedly
and take a class on how to take it in
between almost all the major colleges
are now super scoring the AC T there are
four parts to the AC T and so if you
super score it that means you take the
test and every time you made a little
bit better on one but no better worse on
the other one the section you made
better on all your all your best of on
all four sections are put together
that's called super scoring and so if
you take the test four times and you get
four different grades obviously on each
of the four sections they'll take the
best grade of each section and create a
super score for purposes of getting into
the school now some scholarships won't
count the super score they'll just count
your best a CT score which is fine too
and then one of your other part-time
jobs as you said is applying for
scholarships and grants if she does all
of that with you guys in the background
chunk of money at this and you got two
years of it covered and you just start
thinking about okay what is the goal the
goal is a four-year education that is
usable in the marketplace can we scrape
together the money to pay for that you
can you can actually work your way
through school doing that mathematically
twenty dollars an hour will put you
through school working 30 hours a week
you can do that yes you can chase the
whining is unbelievable working while
you're in college is not child abuse you
can do it I did it how many of you
worked when you were in college raise
your hand out there everybody in the
booth just did I hardly know anybody
that did nothing while they were in
college except go to
class and graduate with a degree in
sorority
I just don't know any of those people I
mean there's a few of them but I mean
the ones that I knew in school there
just wasn't that many ah I work my butt
off I work 40 to 60 hours a week and
graduated in four years with a 297 yes
I'm still pissed about that three 100's
of a point but think about it I worked
my tail end off man and you know you
know why I graduate in four years
because I was tired of giving them money
so I made sure I took every class to get
out of there this was not summer camp
for adolescents this was I want
knowledge a degree check that box move
on into adulthood as fast as I can
that's what happens when you're paying
for it but when you're riding on my butt
meaning I am the idiot taxpayer who
agreed to loan eighteen year olds up to
$100,000 unsecured so they can get a
degree and left-handed puppetry yeah I'm
that idiot taxpayer I've allowed that to
happen when you're riding on me you
don't give a rip